here in this video we will rank 10 of
the hottest godzilla atomic breaths we
will assess all the godzilla
incarnations and their atomic breaths
and this will show you all which one is
the most powerful since the hottest
flame will be the strongest let's just
say that color doesn't really tell the
difference in this power ranking and
just for reference a dragon's flame like
the one that smop from the hobbit has is
estimated to be around just 1200 degrees
celsius
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now with that in mind let's get on with
this video
at number 10 we have zilla's power
breath formerly known as godzilla this
is a film monster originating from the
1998 film godzilla released by tristar
pitchers this godzilla incarnation was
undoubtedly the weakest and doesn't even
have a proper atomic breath but the
power breath that he has was still
deadly as it can burn cars and property
throughout the streets of new york the
zilla that came out in the final wars
movie didn't even get the chance to show
it but but to be honest the flame does
look like it was a little bit more
powerful than a dragon fire so we can
say it's around 1500 degrees
at number nine we have the original
godzilla's atomic breath the original
godzilla and his later returns in the
shower era all had the atomic breath and
the officially stated temperature was a
hundred thousand degrees celsius
godzilla's atomic breath called the
incandescent light or radioactivity
extrusion has typically been shown to
set entire city blocks ablaze and easily
obliterate most military weaponry
with the events of the 1954 film his
atomic breath was presented as a white
mix like blast of course over the years
it became something more than just that
it became sort of a flame and then a
beam
number 8 godzilla 2014 atomic breath it
is kind of surprising to see the monster
vs godzilla so low on this ranking but
this is just a 2014 version of the
atomic breath the emp of the murals
weakened the most important part of the
atomic breath forming process the
electromagnetic charge a weaker charge
means a weaker atomic breath as a result
in kotm his breath was strongest since
demutos were not around and even
stronger since he was supercharged with
a thermal nuclear warhead but in 2014
the amp coupled with just coming out of
hibernation godzilla's atomic breath was
estimated to be around 100 000 to 200
000 degrees
number seven godzilla earth's particle
beam atomic breath
godzilla earth can fire a highly
accelerated charged particle beam called
this atomic breath which is capable of
killing multiple monsters or completely
wiping out entire cities like los
angeles in a single blast godzilla earth
fires this beam from its mouth although
it originates from his electromagnetic
shield the atomic breath generates
powerful electromagnetic waves when
fired which can destroy electronic
devices from more than 300 kilometers
away the energy output from godzilla
earth's atomic breath was measured at 3
terawatts which is roughly between 400
000 to 500 000 degrees celsius
number six singular point and heisei
godzilla's atomic breath the heisei
godzilla's normal atomic breath is
portrayed as a powerful focused blue
laser that burns at 500 000 degrees
celsius and is capable of causing large
explosions and severely wounding some
monsters such as rodan and batra when
fired at point blank range the one from
singular point also has a similar
temperature
even though the way it is seen is more
closely resembling the ping laser beam
of shin godzilla from the 2016 movie
and it was able to blow a hole through
jet jaguar in a single hit
number five godzilla kotm and godzilla
gvk atomic breath in both kotm and jvk
godzilla's atomic breath got an upgrade
and was way more powerful than the one
seen in 2014 it was officially stated
that godzilla's atomic breath has an
energy yield of 3.15 into 10 to the 14th
power of joules
this shows that the titan is capable of
generating an immense amount of power
given the heat behind that power
godzilla is virtually unstoppable so if
we convert it into celsius it would be
more than 500 000 degrees which would
explain why he was able to punch a hole
right to the center of the earth
number 4 godzilla 1994 and final war
spiral heat ray the spiral heat ray is a
more powerful version of the atomic
breath which was the blue radioactive
ray it is used by godzilla in three of
the heisei movies and again in godzilla
final wars the red spiral heat ray used
to kill space godzilla has an official
temperature of 900 000 degrees celsius
and the same can be said about the one
in final wars where he killed kaiser
ghidorah the color of the ray changes
from blue to white to crimson red and
yellow with spirals the beam can cause a
lot more damage than the normal atomic
ray
number 3 godzilla 1993 the spiral heat
ray again in the movie godzilla vs
mechagodzilla 2 godzilla showed the same
move again the spiral heat ray which was
a way more powerful version of the
atomic breath while the heisei
godzilla's atomic breath has an
officially stated temperature of 500 000
degrees the spiral heat rate used
against mechagodzilla 2 has an official
temperature of 1.2 million degrees
celsius it has a main beam and several
other smaller fiery beams that revolve
around the big one this was always
thought to be godzilla's ultimate power
number two shin godzilla's laser atomic
breath
godzilla's atomic breath in shin
godzilla alters depending on how he uses
it and indicates how much power he has
utilized when firing it
originally starting out as a huge
dragonic fire it later evolves into
something different so unlike its
previous iterations godzilla's atomic
ray resembles a focused purple energy
beam the result of which possesses
overwhelming destructive force that not
only crumbles local structures but is
powerful enough to slice through
numerous skyscrapers on the fly
bisecting entire skylines the
temperature of this energy beam is
believed to be more than 1.2 million
degrees celsius that's like being in the
center of the sun
and number one mecha godzilla's proton
scream oh yeah of course this is not
godzilla but mechagodzilla but whatever
mechagodzilla is equipped with a red
energy beam that can burn through adult
skull crawlers
blast through buildings and knock down
as well as burn godzilla this beam can
also beam lock with and defeat
godzilla's atomic breath
although godzilla was not at full
capacity at this time because he was
already using his flame the entire movie
to borrow through the hollow earth and
shoot at kong
this beam was known as the proton scream
and it was powered by a source of energy
that came from the subterranean hollow
earth
this was estimated to be over 5 million
degrees celsius and that my friends is
the hottest flame
so we come to the end of it i hope you
have enjoyed watching this one anyway
let's do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the minecube family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam